bonjour à toutes et tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo où nous allons
parler de strangers heynckes ça me fait
trop plaisir qu'aujourd'hui on parle de
la série car bon sens on aura bien
attendu en vrai mais ça valait le coup
j'ai trouvé la saison 4 incroyable et
enfin on rentre un peu plus dans du
concret dans de la profondeur on ressent
quand même petit à petit qu'on se
rapproche de la fin effectivement pour
celles et ceux qui ne savent pas nous
aurons le volume 2 de cette saison 4 le
1er juillet qui sera composée du coup de
deux épisodes et le tout dernier épisode
durera environ deux heures trente donc
voilà ça promet puis dans le futur nous
aurons encore une saison la cinquième
qui cette fois ci sera la dernière la
véritable fin de strangers in du coup
comme à l'époque de la saison 2 et de la
saison 3 je vous propose qu'on essaye
d'analyser tout ça d'émettre quelques
petites théorie pourquoi pas etc etc je
pense que nous pourrons faire un bo3
théorie sur la saison 4 et la saison 5
mais bon il faudra attendre d'avoir
quand même les deux parties histoire
d'avoir toutes les cartes en main ah oui
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas dit mais
évidemment la vidéo va spoil la saison 4
donc voilà vous êtes prévenus sur ce on
y va cette saison 4 permet de lever le
voile sur pas mal d'éléments et de
consolider l'univers de strangers thing
enfin ils ont amené les autres enfants à
l'écran nous avions la connaissance de
eight alias cali via la saison 2 mais
jamais on nous avait parlé des autres
enfants c'est chose faite désormais et
on comprend mieux pourquoi heleven était
la seule expérience de brenner dans la
saison une en parlant de bray ne retient
on se demandait depuis longtemps si ce
dernier était bel et bien mort ou non on
en avait énormément parlé à l'époque
avec de grandes théories à son égard est
pareil c'est désormais validé brender
est toujours en vie son ancien assistant
apparu en saison 2 10 est donc bel et
bien la vérité brenner est donc toujours
dans le circuit et malheureusement pour
heleven il est la personne qui la
comprend le c'est lui qui l'a façonnée
en quelque sorte également on avait
beaucoup théorisé là-dessus à l'époque
mais on s'attendait à ce que la série à
un moment donné explore un peu plus le
passé de l'univers les frères de feurs
les réalisateurs de la série savent ce
qu'ils font il aime exploiter les
mystères autour de leur univers et il ne
nous laisse que des petites parcelles à
chaque saison par exemple il avait
dévoilé dans une interview à l'époque de
la saison 2 je crois qu'ils avaient un
document de 30 pages sur l'opci down son
fonctionnement ce qu'il symbolise et
cetera ils ont toutes les clés en main
leur univers est solide mais font le
choix délibéré de ne pas tout dévoiler
ce qui est normal après tout donc voilà
tout ça pour dire qu'on s'y attendait un
peu de retourner un peu dans le passé
explorer les origines tout simplement
car on manquait d'informations que ce
soit concernant par exemple l'origine
des enfants
le programme de brenner etc etc ils ont
même justifié le tunnel par lequel
heleven va s'échapper dans la première
saison par le biais de one est justement
one quel pilote whist henry krill le
fils de victor krill one la première
expérience de brenner l'origine du
programme ainsi que vesna la nouvelle
terreur de l'obs aydan trois identités
bien distinctes qui sont en fait la même
personne il va falloir en parler car
même si strangers wings 4 solidifie
l'univers de la série et bien cette
nouvelle saison amène un bon lot de
questions et de mystère et notamment par
le biais de one pour traiter tout ça
j'aimerais que l'on se replonge ensemble
dans le nord entre guillemets de
l'univers retracer tout ce que l'on sait
par rapport à l'obs hayden dans la série
car seul
nous permettrait de pourquoi pas trouver
certaines réponses on sait très peu de
choses sur loeb side armes mais ce que
l'on sait déjà c'est que c'est une sorte
de dimension parallèle à notre univers
comme l'ombre de notre monde la chose la
plus importante à savoir concernant
l'option d'un on a c'est que la faune et
la flore fonctionne comme une seule et
même entité c'est à dire que tout ce qui
est vivant là bas est connectée est plus
que ça encore ils agissent sous le
contrôle du mind flyers leumann flyers
ou flash et leur mental est le dirigeant
entre guillemets de l'obs hayden
l'entité suprême qui contrôle tout il
est la représentation de l'obs hayden en
quelque sorte et nous savons par le
biais de will que son but ultime est
d'effacer la vie et fusionner le monde
réel avec le psy down pour ce faire ce
dernier utilise ces créatures les démos
dogues les démos gorgon ou encore même
les humains qu'il a infecté comme lors
de la saison 3 tout comme le mind flyers
de donjons et dragons il contrôler les
autres par l'esprit et du coup le moyen
de l'arrêter était donc de refermer le
portail pour couper la connexion entre
lui et les hôtes et tout ça c'est hyper
important à garder en tête car même si v
cna est désormais là le mind flyers
reste l'entité primordial de l'occident
comme le dit dustin vesna est le général
cinq étoiles du man fire et c'est le cas
vesna n'est qu'une entité surpuissante
agissant sous les ordres du man flyers
mais c'est là que c'est intéressant car
du coup plusieurs questions découle de
tout ça déjà où est le mind flyers si il
est le grand leader et qu'il est
omnipotent et bien déjà il faut garder
en tête que le psy down étant une
dimension parallèle à notre monde eh
bien elle garde quand même ses codes et
ses principes dans le sens où la
géographie est la même par exemple quand
même si steve robinet et dix sont dans
l'aube saïda hu ils nous font part qu
ils ont onze kilomètres à faire pour se
rendre à l'endroit qu'il souhaite ce que
je veux dire par là c'est que par
exemple cela pourrait expliquer
l'absence du mind flyers dans la
première saison car l'ouverture du
portail avec le démon gorgon était à si
dentelle donc il devait être tout
simplement autre part et là du coup
c'est pareil vu que les russes ont
ouvert un autre portail dans leur pays
le my fire s'y est rendu certainement
dans le but de revenir dans notre monde
sauf que c'est là que c'est très
surprenant dans le petit teaser nous
annonçant la partie de la saison 4 nous
voyons hopper faire face à une cage où
nous voyons une entité en forme de
tornades s'agiter le mind flyer est une
entité composée de tornades il est même
appelé le monstre tornade en saison 2 ce
qui voudrait dire que les russes et
potentiellement réussi à le capturer
cela explique du coup son absence malgré
les nombreux portails générés par v cnaa
hawkins après tout les russes à
kamchatka ont beaucoup plus de moyens
que les gens à hawkins on a tendance à
l'oublier mais nos héros ne sont
simplement que des enfants ou des
adolescents et des adultes classiques
comme joyce hopper ou murray donc
pourquoi pas bon et il est temps de
revenir avec na je vous avoue qu'on ne
sait pas vraiment si one est bel et bien
mort ou s'il est toujours en vie malgré
ce corps je pense qu'il est toujours
vivant en soit vu qu'il prend plaisir à
tuer ses victimes et qu'en plus de ça il
tue ses victimes toujours de la même
manière que quand il était humain mais
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
est sous l'emprise du mind flyers et une
nouvelle fois c'est là qu'il ya quelque
chose d'intéressant à souligner comme
vous le savez le masne flyers veut tuer
tout le monde et prendre possession du
monde sait ce qu'il s'évertue à faire
depuis la saison 2 sauf que dans la
saison 2 heleven lui a fermé le portail
au nez ce qui l'a empêché de continuer
sa quête par le biais des russes via le
centre commercial ce dernier a pu
revenir et plus en colère que jamais il
a désormais conscience de la menace que
représente heleven à son égard et
cherche par tous les moyens de la tuer
il nous le dit par le biais de billy
tout ce qu'il a bâti dans la saison 3
c'est pour pouvoir anéantir heleven qui
est la barrière ultime entre le monde et
le psy down sauf que désormais il y avec
na évêques n'a à l'époque où il était
encore roanne a été battu par la jeune
heleven elle est la seule personne à lui
avoir tenu tête et à le vaincre ce qui
consolide le fait qu'elle haven est la
clé pour défendre la vie face à l'ob
saïda ou non que ce soit le masne flyers
mauvais cna les deux ont déjà perdu face
à heleven en plus de rajouter un aspect
personnel à la relation entre heleven et
le psy down par le biais de one tout est
connecté dans le zeit down de la même
manière que les symbiote pour ceux qui
connaissent bien l'univers marvel et
bien il y a un esprit de ruches une
mémoire collective
vesna et le masne flyers s'autoalimente
entre eux il se pourrait que v cna soit
one est toujours une sorte de libre
arbitre dans le sens où il souhaitait
être libéré de sa condition humaine et
purger l'humanité qu'il considère comme
nuisible one possède les mêmes objectifs
que le mind flyers donc c'est comme
s'ils travaillaient main dans la main
étant donné que dans la saison 2 et plus
particulièrement la saison 3 le mind
flyers a été confronté directement à
elven et a même perdu v cnad par le
concept de mémoire collective a
désormais conscience qu'elle haven est
toujours en vie et c'est pourquoi il
agit désormais un portail a été ouvert
en russie pour effectuer la connexion
avec le monde réel et c'est ce qui lui
permet d'agir et de créer de nouveaux
portails avec pour but à la fin de
retrouver les bonnes et se venger et du
coup il semblerait que brender et owen
sont au courant de pas mal de choses
déjà concernant tout ça puisque de par
les caméras de surveillance brender
c'est ce qu'il s'est exactement passé la
nuit du 8 septembre
1979 il sait quel even a délivré one et
que ce dernier a tué tout le monde sauf
que comme le démontre la fin de la série
et leeuwen a simplement banni one dans
l'aube saïda avec le temps et de
nombreuses expériences par le biais des
levels brenner va finalement trouver le
démo gorgon par erreur et quand il va
rentrer en contact avec un nouveau
portail va s'ouvrir et là encore une
fois il ya une seconde lecture car comme
le dit si bien one samedi
il se pourrait que depuis toujours
brenner cherche à reproduire ce qu'est
leeuwen a effectué la nuit du 8
septembre
1979 il se pourrait que le démon gorgon
trouver dans la saison une n'était pas
une erreur mais bel et bien ce que
convoitait brenner qui a été témoin de
ce qu'a pu faire heleven quand elle
était petite et là c'est un point que je
trouve hyper intrigant et qui sera
certainement répondu dans l'avenir de la
série c'est le fait qu'ils aient leeuwen
possède des pouvoirs qui sont liées à
l'obs down et aucune information nous a
été donnée ou explications concernant
tout ça heleven sans le savoir à benny
waters loppsi down plus tard elle va
trouver sans faire exprès le démo gorgon
qui va lancer la série et ouvrir un
véritable portail entre les deux mondes
elle a le pouvoir de refermer ce même
portail et même de confronter le mind
flyers lui même nous ne savons pas la
source des pouvoirs des enfants nous ne
savons pas pourquoi ils ont des pouvoirs
et nous ne savons que très peu de choses
de l'up side out mais il ya clairement
un lien entre heleven et lepphaille down
et il est possible que brender en savent
quelque chose et que ce soit l'une des
clefs de l'avenir de la série s'il ya
bien une question hockey strangers singh
ne répond jamais c'est
le pourquoi pourquoi les pouvoirs
pourquoi le mind flyers pourquoi le
programme de brenner pourquoi avec na
nous avons toujours des réponses
partielles mais jamais de véritables
raisons et moi perso je suis sûr que ce
sera la kz2 l'avenir de la série est
bien évidemment heleven comme toujours
semble être la clé de voûte de de tout
ça quoi mais bon là on commence à
s'écarter un petit peu enfin un dernier
point très mystérieux sur lequel
j'aimerais m'arrêter c'est la nouvelle
information concernant loppsi d'armes
qui nous a été dévoilée par nancy c'est
le fait que l'opci down propose une
copie de la planète mais du passé comme
si la temporalité de la dimension était
en arrêt comme coincé effectivement
nenci nous apprend que dans la dimension
nous sommes toujours le 6 novembre 1983
soit trois ans avant la saison 4 et par
extension le jour même où il a été
enlevé par le démon gorgon dans le
premier épisode de la saison une cette
information est intrigante car il est
difficile de se dire à quoi elle sert
encore une fois c'est la question
pourquoi pourquoi sommes-nous dans le
passé dans l'obs aydan j'ai peut-être
une idée mais c'est un peu farfelue vous
me direz ce que vous en pensez l'obs
hayden est une dimension parallèle à
notre monde normalement sauf que
logiquement vu que tout y est géré par
le mind flyers et qu'il n'a aucune
connaissance de notre réalité de son
évolution ce que je veux dire par là
assez comment l'homme a façonné le monde
à travers les âges et bien le style down
reste une terre vaste composé de roches
et de montagne one étant la première
personne connue de la série à mettre les
pieds là-bas dû à son bannissement c'est
comme ça que l'on voit le psy down sauf
que par le biais du premier véritable
portail ouvert le 6 novembre 83 à cause
du contact entre heleven et le démo
gorgon les mondes se sont reliés ce jour
là et le psig down a pu prendre copie de
notre monde je ne sais pas si vous voyez
exactement ce que je veux dire et puis
surtout vu que le mind flyers contrôler
les gens par l'esprit il a pu
possiblement refaçonner le pss hayden en
fonction de la connaissance des gens
qu'ils contrôlent par exemple en
fonction de wild side and à une
représentation de hopkins ainsi que du
château byers que personne ne
connaissait vraiment à part lui sa
famille et ses amis et du coup on le
retrouve dans l'aube saïda après
peut-être que je vais trop loin et que
ce simplement par le biais des portails
qui établissent là connexion entre notre
monde et le monde à l'envers mais je
vous avoue que pour le moment je n'ai
pas de véritable explication
néanmoins en tout cas plus nous avançons
plus le psy down évolue et se forme en
fonction de notre monde à la base un
monde désolé nous avons désormais une
représentation complète dao keynes et un
ou plusieurs portails ont été ouverts en
russie au vu du but ultime du mind
flyers plus nous avançons plus le pseye
down ressemble aux véritables monde
est-ce que cela ne traduirait pas que
plus nous avançons plus la réalité se
mélangent avec loppsi down jusqu'à ne
former plus qu'un ou du moins que le
braille down deviennent de plus en plus
dangereux bref tout est possible
nous arrivons à la fin de cette vidéo je
suis très heureux d'avoir pu vous parler
de strangers things j'adore cette série
et ça fait vraiment du bien de la revoir
au devant de la scène n'hésitez pas à me
faire part de ce que vous en avez pensé
personnellement j'ai trouvé la partie
une de la saison 4 franchement grandiose
et j'ai plus que de voir la partie 2 le
1er juillet comptez sur moi en tout cas
pour vous en reparler j'espère
d'ailleurs que ma vidéo vous aura plu et
vous aura potentiellement apporter
certaines réponses dans tous les cas
cela n'engage que ma vision tout est
possible le débat reste ouvert nous
avons très très peu de réponses sur le
braille d'armes donc voilà n'hésitez pas
à me faire part de vos idées vos
ressentis concernant tout ça dans les
commentaires en attendant n'oubliez pas
le petit pouce bleus n'hésitez pas non
plus à vous abonner pour ne pas louper
les prochaines vidéos et puis bah voila
quoi c'était argot rock que le lionheart
soit avec vous allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]